hello everybody it is June first so it's
time for another monthly update video in
which I'm going to talk about what went
on during the month of May and what
we've got coming up during June - very
packed months a lot of really cool stuff
I always like to begin by talking about
three big things and I'm very excited
about all of these these three big
things because they have to do with
things that I consider to be really cool
so the first big thing is that at long
last I have actually created a patreon
site for not only this channel but my
other YouTube channels my to support my
blogging work and all the other things
that I essentially do for free bringing
philosophy to you know a worldwide
audience through the internet so I'll
talk more about that in just a few
moments the second big thing another
thing that I'm really excited about is
that the webinar and online seminar for
this month we had a little change of
plans is going to be focused on Hegel's
master-slave dialectic so if you've ever
been puzzled about that
or if you think that's really
interesting stuff you want to get in on
that the third thing is that this month
come hell or high water I am going to
get the Aristotle categories on demand
you know go at your own pace class
completely finished up to my standards
and released for the general public so
that's a lot of cool stuff already now
let's talk about the month of May so a
lot of events many of them face-to-face
many of them online we kicked off the
month by having another of the
installations of the Philosopher's in
the midst of history lectures this one
was on
Boethius king theodoric and the
beginning of the Middle Ages you can see
the video link below we also continued
our worlds of speculative fiction I
think this would have been lecture
number 17 in the series this time focus
Orson Scott Card's Ender's Game series
what we call the underverse a lot of
great discussion in that we had online
webinar and seminars this time focused
on epictetus dichotomy of control so
that was a lot of fun did a half-hour
Hagel Q&A session supported by the
half-hour Hagel project we had our MKE
that is Milwaukee stoic fellowship
meeting towards the end of the month so
that's already quite a bit now like I
mentioned before we also started a
patreon page for supporting the work
that I do with this channel and in a lot
of other venues online so I want to talk
about that for a few moments patreon is
a crowdfunding site that means that
people make donations in this case it's
not like Kickstarter people make monthly
commitments and all of that goes to help
defray the costs and to you know provide
me with a living as I produce you know
video content blog content eventually
I'd actually like to start doing
podcasting and a lot of the work that I
do requires a good bit of preparation so
this is a way that people can support
the production of the the philosophical
resources that they love people have
been asking me why don't you do a
patreon page for quite a while and I
finally you know mulled it over talked
it over with Andy and we decided that it
was a good idea so that rolled out
officially I think two days ago and we
already have seven people supporting the
work that I do so that's really awesome
if you really like the stuff that I've
been producing consider becoming a
supporter you get cool perks at certain
levels and so all of that information is
below you just click on the link and it
will take you to the page and you can
check it out now another thing that went
on a little bit earlier in the month
was an interview with
the painted porch run by Scott Pirie the
stoic guitarist that I'll put a link to
below we talked about creativity and
what stoicism and the dichotomy of
control has to say about that I also did
quite a lot of tutorial work and
philosophical counseling work I actually
picked up a few more clients some some
additional coaching I did a lot of work
you know with with stoicism today not
just editing and writing some content
but also behind the scenes
organizational things as we start
leading up to the fall when stoic weak
and stoic on are going to be here what
else I've been working on the classes as
well I didn't get the categories
completely finished as I wanted to you
know I want to have them really great
quality lots and lots of content before
I open them up to the public and I've
been you know building curriculum as
well for priority thinking this is
really interesting stuff that we've got
going on in the partnership with them
and I've been engaged in a partnership
as well having to do with some ethics
consulting that I'll talk more about
down the line once once that's taken
some fuller shape writing I've been
getting some progress done on the book
projects some meaning not as much as I'd
like but that's typical for writing
isn't it I I did some blogging in in a
wreck fifteen write decay and in in
medium and in hatha or Hegel blog I'm
really happy that I did also get some
writing done in a blog that I haven't
contributed to for really two years and
that is the heavy metal philosopher I
finally got some wind in my sails
there's two pieces in there recently
about identity and the nature of bands
video work I shot my my my six half-hour
Hegel videos for the month getting it's
almost to the end of the very first
subsection of the first section of the
Spirit
portion of the work shot a lot of
aristotle's categories videos finished
at that core concept series up I shot
some personal videos one that I remember
because I shot it recently was one about
why in fact I work on on YouTube doing
philosophy here you know bringing all
this content to people you know what the
reasoning behind it is and of course we
recorded our various events the
epictetus webinar so you can see the
videos for those below as well june is
going to be an extraordinarily busy
month i just looking at the calendar
i've got a whole bunch of dates down
there i'll talk about that in just a
second but another thing that that's
very cool about june is my children will
be coming for summer vacation and
staying with us for a number of weeks i
always love having them here especially
here in downtown Milwaukee where there
are so many cool things to see do walk
around in you know events so I'm really
looking forward to that so we kick off
on Wednesday the 7th from 5 to 6 p.m.
Central time with our monthly half-hour
hagel Q&A that's another patreon
supported project they have our Haegele
project my supporters are in effect
underwriting me offering a Q&A session
on anything Haegele related to the
general public on the 8th locally here
Thursday June 8th 7 to 8 p.m. at the
Brookfield Public Library we're
continuing with the philosophy and
speculative fiction series this time
we're going to be talking about Ian
banks or I in banks culture series I'm
not sure how it's pronounced I should
probably find that out before I get
there on the 15th which is a Thursday
from 5 to 6 p.m. Central Time again we
will have our our new philosophy checks
this is for patreon supporters at the
the I think $10 level per month I am
creating a new venue for them to come
and ask me anything that they want about
philosophy or talk whatever they want
about philosophy with me for an hour as
a perk for them on the 20th which is a
Tuesday we begin our seminar slash
webinar series for the month 12 p.m.
Central Time we're going to focus on
Hegel's master-slave dialectic it will
be a 45-minute free webinar on the 22nd
which is a Thursday at the Shorewood
Public Library I believe that is 6:00
p.m. we will be continuing our women you
should read discussion series this time
focusing on the great medieval figure
thinkers scholar who didn't
unfortunately write as much as we'd have
liked Eloise well known for her romance
with Peter Abelard which turned out very
badly for both of them but particularly
for him if you know what I'm talking
about then on the 24th which is a
Saturday at 10 a.m. and 4 p.m. we have
our two-hour intensive online seminars
on Hegel's master-slave dialectic so if
you you know go to the webinar and you
want a little bit more you might want to
check those out and the 29th which is a
Thursday we have our MKE stoic
fellowship meeting it's a monthly
meeting here in Milwaukee although we do
that some people come up from Illinois
and even Michigan to attend and we're
talking about Epictetus still going
through some of the things in the
enchiridion and finally one of the
things that's going to be going on where
I'm not talking but I actually get to be
a participant for once is the Marquette
Aristotle conference which runs from
Monday to wednesday the 26th to the 28th
Marquette is just you know 10 blocks
from here and I'm going to walk over and
get to hear some great papers on
Aristotle engage
some discussion and you know catch up
with a few old friends and colleagues
it's gonna be great this is a very
important thing for me to sort of
refresh myself in in my my work what
else still you know carrying on a lot of
tutoring work philosophical counseling
and coaching doing the editorial stuff
for stoicism today if by the way you're
interested in tutoring services or
philosophical counseling or coaching
services you can go to the reason aisle
website or you can just email me
directly at Gregg at reason I oh I am
taking on new clients or for both of
those happy to work with with anybody
who finds philosophy to be interesting
or useful in those respect writing I
have to get a paper out today later
today that that I wrote fortunately it
has to be polished up and sent out on
and some from the st. Anselm conference
I'm still working on the book projects
particularly the one on stoicism and
anger and doing some other collaborative
work with a few other people as well on
some writing projects I'm going to be
doing some more blogging hopefully this
month in rexis do a 2k 1/2 or Hegel
heavy metal philosopher I'm hoping to
get a partially examined life article
out I will also have a piece of stoicism
today later on this month and maybe also
in policy of truth and also you know I'm
adding articles and the medium thing so
if you want to check that out as well
you can see some some nice pieces there
classes I'm going to be finishing up
that Aristotle categories class I've
just got to you know tidy up some of the
pages and do a few more handouts and
there's a few other things I want to do
a show with a few videos I want to shoot
for that as well so that will be out
sometime this month and open for the
public it's an on-demand class will also
have Cicero's stoic paradoxes either
this month or next month and I'm also
working on a little mini course on
Plato's I
that I think that people might find
interesting and useful as well video
work so this is where it gets really
interesting of course I'm doing the half
hour Hegel you know making our way
through this very interesting spirit
section and I've shot some core concept
videos on Cicero's stove paradoxes that
I will be releasing in in this next week
but we also have a poll that if you want
to you can participate in I'm looking
for input from my viewers and
subscribers about what figures they
would most like to see me working on
over the summer with the core concept
videos because there's a lot of gaps
right there's a lot of philosophers who
could be commented on and if I'm
competent to talk about that philosopher
I am definitely willing to do it so I
want to get input from people about what
it is that they'd really like to see
I'll also try to shoot some more of the
personal videos I know people have been
asking for them and enjoy them so I'll
probably do some more of those in the
coming weeks as well so that is a pretty
packed month sometimes it even makes me
anxious about how much I'll be able to
get done during it you know when I get
closer to the end of the month and
there's deadlines you know I get a bit
concerned about whether I'm going to
meet them or not beginning of the month
is always a bit nicer that way and so
that's where we are so you have a great
month and I've got a lot coming up that
you might want to take a look at